now shows like madmen Sopranos Game of
Thrones they all have an ongoing
storyline over the course of the entire
run but they also have multi multiple
mini stories in each episode now the a
story is the main story of the week that
follows the characters dilemma the
hero's dilemma the BCD stories in
television also have something to do
with the main hero but they're different
stories and they alternate in a very
particular way and it doesn't matter who
you are as a creator you will always
alternate your structure in this general
way Soderbergh Cronenberg even David
Lynch he's probably dragged kicking and
screaming but he follows this form as
well if you don't follow it great I'm
happy I love that you're gonna break
these rules but you have to show me that
the story's gonna work if you want to be
the first to break this pattern I'm with
you but the pattern to be broken has to
be broken in a way I've never seen let's
try it next time we do a consult now
here are the four storylines in mr.
robot can the hero Elliot stop the big
villains the bank can he find them and
stop them he has to find them that's
Creed this is a mystery thriller can
Elliot and his best girl who's not his
sexual romantic partner can they bond
and help each other heal that's the B
story line C is will Helia team up with
his mentor in this story mr. robot to
bring down the corrupt system and the
fourth the D storyline is will Elliott
save his shrink from her horrible
boyfriend each of these storylines get
asked in the cold open in the first act
and they get answered by the end of the
fourth act they all get wrapped up and
that is critical every one of your
storylines in television must be wrapped
up and answered yes or no by the end of
the show so how does this four story
line work in mr. robot okay so mr. robot
and we already know what the log line is
let's ask ourselves what's the hook well
we already said we want to see this
cyber vigilante went against the matrix
okay we want to see whether he can do it
and in the cold open of this story now I
suggest you guys get the opening pilot
episode of mr. robot up with you on your
screen and watch this with me so you'll
understand this
really well or get the script either one
I can't show it to you here for
copyright reasons but I urge you to go
through it with me and by the way guys I
really urge you to get the script and
watch it as you watch the episode it's
amazing what you learn when you do that
now this is a mystery thriller now a few
years ago all I did was movies I didn't
do television at all now 80% of my
business is television maybe 90 I
learned a lot about movie genre and I
learned a lot about mystery sellers I
have a book coming out on it mystery
thrillers in movies I thought oh god
when television began such a big deal I
thought am I even gonna work can I take
what I've learned in movies and put them
in television the great answer is yes
everything I've learned about movies
work in television there's only two big
differences we already mentioned heroes
don't change people don't change and you
can tell a lot more than show those are
the two critical differences between
movies and TV everything else is the
same
all the genre patterns I'm gonna show
you work in television just as they do
in movies and mr. robot is a mystery
thriller what does that mean one of the
reasons one of the things that means is
that the villain is hidden and he's not
a small villain he's a huge villain he
is the most malevolent villain you could
ever imagine
but he's hidden at the beginning of the
story so when we open mr. robot how do
we open it Elliot says in a vo there is
a conspiracy bigger than all of us
it's a group of people that we don't
know the one percent against the 99 and
as he tells us this we see the shadowy
mostly probably white men standing
around behind a boardroom and we don't
see their faces why because remember in
a mr. pillar whether it's Chinatown LA
Confidential salt any of these movies
the hit the real villain is hidden at
the beginning of the story we don't see
him but everything happens because of
him there's a powerful group of people
out there and they run the world
yes they're invisible now mystery
thrillers are very hot in television
right now I urge you to think about
making one man on the high castle which
is a brilliant adaptation of a Philip
dick story X is an adaptation since the
loose
they're completely changing it Jessica
Jones mr. robot mystery throws many
coming I'm working on several right now
so just let's look at what a mystery
thriller means mystery thrillers about
hidden evil whether it's Maltese Falcon
or Inception or LA Confidential or salt
thrillers are not it's not the same as a
thriller in a thriller the villain comes
out and you and you see the hero
battling him very fairly quickly you may
not know who he is but you see him
battling him but that's true in seven
but it's not true insult or inception
because in a mystery thriller there's
three levels of story plot okay stay
with me guys this is a little
complicated but you need to know this
because mr. robot has them all and the
reason they have them is the mystery
thriller audience wants to be baffled
you ever seen anybody who loves to do
crosswords they're looking at the New
York Times crossword puzzle and what are
they doing they're going oh my god oh my
god I don't think I can solve it Oh
Peter I don't think I can solve it oh my
god what is that that's the adrenaline
that comes from for you looking at a
puzzle not being able to solve it then
when they do solve one what do they do
they go oh they get a kind of a dopamine
high it's a kind of an orgasm because
they have it's now solve the mystery
that's all mystery thriller does for you
it poses a mystery and then it lets you
solve it okay not my genre when I went
to Inception I was like what the hell's
happening I'm gonna go I'm gonna leave
the theater but the mystery thriller
audience loves that mystery now that
means they crave a complicated story so
there's three stories and mr. fillers
there is the distraction plot that is
what you see quickly in act 1 that looks
like the real crime that's going on in
the story but it's actually just a
distraction the second plot is the
emotional change in the hero that helps
them solve the crime and the third plot
is the real crime what's really going on
that does not get revealed till act 5 in
the story now it's hidden okay so in
this story it's the fact that this bank
runs our world this bank controls all of
us but that's not what we see at the
beginning of the story ok what do we see
we see a hero with a core wound if you
look at the beginning of the story
you'll see that Elliott is
sitting in a subway with his hoodie on
he's got hooded eyes he looks like a
crazy guy he's a great actor and he is a
crazy guy he's paranoid he believes that
the world's out to get him and in fact
he's mentally ill his core wound is that
he cannot cannot connect to people that
he is alone that he's helpless that he
is emotionally unable to ever be with
anybody and so what we see in the cold
open which simply means the first five
pages of the script the first five
minutes of the story we see him on a
subway we see him saying there's all
these crazy people out here in there and
there's there's conspiracy to damage us
all and then we see him suddenly say
I should have gone to Angela's
birthday party why do we see those two
things because the B story here is can
Eliot bond to his friend Angela and not
feel alone so we're gonna see the a and
the B story in the cold open you always
do later we're gonna see what those two
are in Breaking Bad the cold open gives
us those two storylines and they're
gonna alternate through the entire rest
of the our pilot he says I should have
gone to Angela's birthday party but I
didn't because I cannot connect to
people guys if you want to give us
sympathy for your hero show his core
wound or her core wound immediately show
it in the first minute of the story if
you've ever done it in a note that says
mmm your hero was in sympathetic it's
because you're not showing their core
wound what makes you like someone not
because the rich or famous are strong
that doesn't find what makes you like
someone when they show you the wrong
ability when they show that they are
screw-ups just like you this is what
great stories do immediately and this is
what we get with with Eliot
you